exactamente creo que yo bailé trato de
enfocar este discurso en el rol
principal que tiene que jugar eeuu de
cara a esta crisis en europa por
relación de rusia y ucrania el rol de
liderazgo que ha jugado además en el
último año con el más de los más de 1000
millones de dólares que ha donado en
eeuu a ucrania con para la asistencia
militar yo bailén resaltó la cantidad de
veces que él le informó al mundo y hace
lentes que a ucrania que se prepararon
porque venía un ataque ruso y pues
repitió varias veces que él tenía la
inteligencia que la compartió a todo el
mundo y pues en varias ocasiones
selenski varios países europeos pues se
trataron de contrarrestar de minimizar
estas alertas de eeuu y él insistió en
que a pesar de todo este eeuu ha dado el
apoyo no solamente militar sino también
humanitario que ha requerido que está
pidiendo por lo michelle es que
presidente ucraniano es de resaltar en
el tema de ucrania el anuncio que hace
hoy yo oval del que seguramente pues
era apoyo bipartidista es el anuncio de
que cierra el cielo cierra el espacio
aéreo para los aviones rusos esta medida
se había adoptado en las últimas horas
por la unión europea y eeuu se suma
entonces a esta medida para que ningún
avión ruso pueda sobrevolar espacio
aéreo estadounidense esto bloquea
bastante la economía de rusia en temas
comerciales y esto este anuncio también
adicionalmente con lo que dijo sobre
putin diciendo que está putin más
aislado que nunca y que sus acciones han
hecho que europa y eeuu se unan aún más
que occidente esté cada vez más unido en
cuanto footing aguanta más en ucrania
frente a estos anuncios lo que terminó
pasando en la sala plena del senado es
que de la cámara representantes es que
tantos senadores demócratas como
republicanos se pararon y aplaudieron
durante varios segundos eso no se veía
y no se vio durante
mucho tiempo sobre todo en la
administración
de el pasado presidente de donald trump
la división la polarización en eeuu ha
sido un tema bastante recurrente
bastante alarmante y el y esta crisis e
tema este precisó el tema de ucrania
está haciendo que es que se paren los
dos partidos y que aplaudan la labor y
lo que está diciendo el presidente yo
bailé en varias varias cosas noticiosas
entre otros te lo mencionaba el anuncio
de pues delegar de crear un cargo de un
fiscal que
investigue los fraudes pandémicos los
fraudes de empresas que durante la
administración pasada se aprovecharon de
estos fondos que puso a disposición la
administración para las pequeñas
empresas pero que las grandes empresas
por sus habilidades legales y por
conocer mejor la ley fueron las que
terminaron aprovechándose de estos
pequeños préstamos que iban a pequeñas
empresas sobre este tema fue muy
enfático también el presidente yo bailé
él quiere que las grandes empresas
paguen lo justo resaltó cómo muchas
empresas que están entre las 500
empresas más grandes del mundo acá en
eeuu simplemente no están pagando
impuestos y él reiteró varias veces él
dijo que él es capitalista pero no se
puede pensar en un capitalismo donde no
hay competencia un capitalismo donde no
hay competencia precisamente termina
generando oligopolios estos oligopolios
terminan subiendo los precios de los
consumidores que no terminan ayudando
precisamente al tema de la inflación
porque suben los precios de los
productos y los servicios en ese tema
por ejemplo fue enfático también al
resaltar lo que se tiene que hacer para
reducir los precios de los medicamentos
en este punto también fue aplaudido
tanto por demócratas y republicanos
porque pues ésta también ha sido una
política que ha tratado de impulsar
administraciones pasadas republicanas de
que las farmacéuticas pues reduzcan ese
poder que tienen haya más competencia y
los precios por ende disminuyan mencionó
el tema de la insulina hizo pues ejemplo
a un niño que invitó precisamente al
estado de la unión a su discurso como
ejemplo de los altos precios que pagan
los estadounidenses por la insulina y
pues este tema entonces de los
medicamentos desde el poder de las
empresas pues fue recurrente en su
discurso obviamente hay que resaltar
también que para responder concretamente
a su pregunta si este tema de ucrania
pues va a unir un poco más a eeuu
va a tratar de mitigar estas diferencias
tan grandes que hay entre republicanos y
demócratas porque recordemos que apenas
hace unos meses antes de este conflicto
china era el foco de la política
exterior estadounidense y ahora ucrania
parece que puede emitir estas
diferencias entre republicanos y
demócratas